the problem is where you might have a
million things but you want two million
things and you will not be happy
right and so you can simply change how
happy you are
by expecting
[Music]
what's going on everyone i hope you're
having a phenomenal weekend
restful time um this podcast is
dedicated to all of the
uh younger entrepreneurs out there so
this is a little departure from the
normal business owner but i think that
you'll still find value in it if you
know any younger entrepreneurs or you
have
uh you know teenagers or kids or you
know college you know college aged
people
slash maybe even people in their 20s 30s
right who are getting into business and
so maybe you left your job and you're
getting into business now whatever right
this would apply to you
and it's regarding expectations
and i think that expectations are
literally the thing that will destroy
your life
uh or will make your life and many of us
uh i think many people in general have
you know figured out and many world
religions have figured this out which is
uh you know the secret to happiness is
uh
haves over wants uh which is
let's say you have you know have one
thing
and you want nothing you will be
infinitely happy
the problem is where you might have a
million things but you want two million
things and you will not be happy
right and so you can simply change how
happy you are
by expecting less and so one of the
things that i specifically wanted to
address today was the
expectations around education and
the reason this is a really meaningful
topic for me is that i think i've talked
to you about my neighbor
and watching him go through the the
crazy expectations that he has
as a young person has been really
valuable for me because i've also seen
a lot of those characteristics that he
has in myself just add zeros
to it but it's still fundamentally the
same thing and that's what's been
uh it's been meaningful for me and so
anyways
uh i have tried to frame things
uh so if you are trying to learn things
which is going to be the first step to
any kind of entrepreneurial endeavor
is i like to liken everything to a
bridge because i think it's a simple
visual
so imagine where you are on one side of
you know this this valley right is where
you are and where you want to go
is on the other side of this big valley
right and you have a bridge that goes
across the two sides
now the problem is is that people will
buy
things they will buy courses they will
buy mentorships they'll buy workshops
they'll buy seminars they'll buy events
they'll buy whatever right
in an effort on some level to get over
this bridge
right of where they are to where they
want to go and it could be from
zero to a hundred thousand dollars a
year it could be from a million dollars
a month to two million dollars a month
it could be from a hundred million
dollars a year to a billion dollars a
year whatever it is there's a bridge
right
and along that bridge
are bricks and i like to liken um
each skill as a brick on the way
to where you're trying to go and the
problem
with the expectations of somebody who's
trying to learn a skill or achieve a
goal
is that they have a binary outcome i
either achieved it or i did not i either
am making a hundred thousand dollars or
i am not and the problem is it can be
incredibly frustrating
because if you have a binary outcome
then it's very easy to get a zero out of
one
right where the reality is
most things are exist on a continuum and
so this is the difference between
a psychological binary and a and and the
biological continuum which is i'll give
you a couple of examples
so it's not uh uh are you diabetic or
you're not diabetic it's
how diabetic are you right it's not uh
are you smart are you dumb but it's how
smart are you right
and so we like to psychologically bucket
things into yes
knows because it's simpler for us but it
it it misses
actual reality right and this can be
especially dangerous as we're trying to
acquire new skills
and so the reason i liken this and i
think it's so dangerous in education
uh because that's what we're doing right
if we're trying to educate ourselves
trying to acquire skills
is that we think as we're trying to get
across this bridge that let's say you
buy a course
on copywriting right and so you're on
one side of the bridge
you buy a course on copywriting and then
you still aren't a millionaire
wow right the problem is
you may have put another brick on your
bridge you may be closer
to where you were to getting to the
other side of the bridge you just
haven't achieved it yet
and so this is one of the issues that i
also see um
just in general like it's so funny
because in the in the in the i'll say
quote guru world
um you know people will take on a coach
that coach will move them forward
you know to a certain degree and then
they'll take another coach and that
coach will move them forward to a
certain degree
and so forth and so on and then the
thing is is that they're they're like
i'm working with so-and-so i used to
work with that person they suck right
but the problem and i used to do this
right like and this is why i think it's
so ridiculous
um is that like if you were looking at
your schooling right and you had a
had a third grade math teacher and then
later you had a calculus teacher
you wouldn't be like screw that third
grade you know uh
math teacher the stuff that i'm learning
from this guy is so much you know more
advanced whatever right
and i've had you know a lot of our
clients say that about their franchises
that they work with and things like that
and i just
it it drives me nuts because it's it's
it's stupid you know it's for lack of
it's stupid
because a lot of times you need you need
step one to get to step two
right and you don't have to and p it's
because people have psychological issues
but like
they they can't they can't say i've
learned from all of these people
right and it doesn't it doesn't decrease
your status to say i've learned from
many teachers look at all the richest
people in the world they say like
i've had multiple mentors i've had so
many people help me out over the years
and i think if you can shift that
perspective it will be incredibly
valuable for you
but one of the other things that's so
poisonous about especially in the like
the quote make money world
is that if we if if everyone in the
world viewed
college because i think about this a lot
i'm like why is it that people will
spend two hundred thousand dollars
four years of their lives study you know
aztec literature of the 1700s and get to
the end and not in any way be upset
about the fact that they're not making
money when they graduate they can't even
get a job
like why is that and the only reason
that i can come up with is that they
didn't expect to
right and so that's it like that's the
difference is that people come in
and part of that is because the
marketing messaging and the sales and
all that kind of stuff so don't be wrong
like
the reason that you know the big
academic uh powerhouse has been able to
stay there
well one is because they got the
government to get on board and give away
free money so that's obviously one part
of it
but the other part of it is that when
people are coming in they
they expect nothing like nothing
literally they're not expecting anything
they expect to get a
check mark next to the name that says
you have a diploma congratulations right
and so uh if my my
my my request of everyone um and i've
requested this of myself
is that when i go into trying to learn
something that i do not have give myself
a binary outcome
of uh did this work or did not work but
instead give
myself the question am i closer or
further away from my goal
and i think that has been tremendously
helpful i've i've spent i mean recently
i i
spent fifty thousand dollars on uh i
think eight hours
with someone uh it was different than uh
the the grant cardone one that i did
um that's that was four hours for 120
000 if you're curious
um and honestly i got enough value in
the first hour that i was like
i don't know what i'm gonna do with the
next three calls um with grant it was
really good
um but the point is is you know with the
other one that i did
it was actually to have assistance on a
higher level project that i was working
on
and about halfway through i realized
that um it was not a priority
uh for me and so i could either say this
got me you know i'm not gonna be like
hey screw this guy right or anything
like that
it was just um for me if i can get the
perspective that something is not a
priority that is valuable in and of
itself and so
does that take me closer or further to
my ultimate goal closer and so why would
i be
satisfied and so shifting uh
our education expectations to
is this another brick on the bridge to
where i'm trying to go
or instead of excuse me instead of
am i at my destination or not and i
think that this is probably one of the
biggest things that you can do
or like that it's or it's been useful
for me
and this is what i've tried to shift my
neighbor's perspective
uh for himself on which is it's kind of
alignment with that kind of investor
mindset which is
if i were to look over a five year time
horizon and i were to continue to
acquire skills like this would i and i
put more and more bricks on my
bridge by the end of that period
would i be better or worse off and
likely it'd be better but you
will be worse off if you keep trying to
build a new bridge right and that's why
when you jump from opportunity to
opportunity
a lot of times you can never get to
where you're trying to go because you
take two steps
of progress and say oh i'm not there
binary outcome therefore i will start
something else
and it's only after failing three four
five six things then on the seventh
thing
you had enough acquired skills from your
first six failures that you are actually
able to make it all the way across the
bridge
and that's what's kind of interesting
about this is that like there are plenty
of people
who uh you know have come to us
and immediately start making a lot of
money right and then they and then
they're like oh my god gem launch is
awesome and the thing is is that like
i we don't honestly deserve all the
credit because
you probably like some of these people
may have gone through three four five
courses that
they believe failed them when in reality
there may be 38 skill sets that
they need to create their their business
you know core skills
and they may have acquired 24 of them
from other people
and we just happen to be able to get
them the last 14 that gets them all the
way across but because they have a
binary outcome
expectation they then attribute all the
credit to us and i don't think that's
fair
um you know uh to themselves in terms of
their mental space but also to everyone
else that they've worked with right
and so i think thinking about it this
way has been
really helpful and especially and this
is again i mentioned the franchisor one
earlier but i'm gonna say it again
i i can't tell you the amount of
facilities specifically that worked for
the franchisor and then said you know
started working with us started making
more money and we're like
i hate my franchisor you got you know
like screw them blah blah blah
but the reality is that many times they
wouldn't have even survived long enough
without the
the fundamental bricks that had been
laid by the franchisor with their
business model there's so many
fundamentals that they may not even been
aware of
and mistakes that they would have made
that were avoided because
the franchisor got them 70 percent of
the way across the bridge right
um and we just got them the last 30
right and so
um another perspective on this as well
is that let's say you've got two people
who all have who both have all 38 bricks
on this bridge right
on the on the path of your opportunity
vehicle you're trying to pursue to get
to the other side right
now let's say both of them have all both
all 38 bricks
but with your learning style and their
teaching style
you're only able to accurate or you know
absorb
25 of the first guys right it's kind of
the same thing
right it's like for some reason like you
know i maybe the first ones you worked
with taught you how to sell but
like you didn't absorb or wasn't real
for you and then later on in your life
uh you it was able to be real for you
and then you attribute your success
uh to the second person when in reality
the first person helped you along the
way
and so um this has just been really
valuable uh for me from a shift in
perspective
in my overall happiness um but also
just in thinking about outcomes and what
what what do i believe is reasonable
and i think i've been i've been asking
myself this question much
more frequently which is do i believe my
expectations are reasonable
and is there a way that i can lower them
and uh
there's there's difference between
lowering your expectations of the
performance you want of people i believe
you should be absolutely intolerant of
people who do not want to be world class
at something
or you should be intolerant of any lack
of effort
but if you can maintain absolute
intolerance to anything but excellence
but then also decrease your expectations
of the outcome
then that is going to be a winning
formula so increase expectations on
activity and actions
decrease expectations on outcomes and i
think that that is a formula for
business success just as
uh haves over wants
is a uh formula for happiness in life
and so anyways i figured i would share
that with you
um just quick quick recap of takeaways
try not to think about things at least
for me this has been valuable i have
shifted to
going from binary is this good is this
bad two how good is it
and instead of thinking uh this is what
needs to happen is
is a first is that a reasonable
expectation and b can i lower it
and b and c can i raise my expectations
of the activities
that i would be willing to take to make
my very low expectation
so believably reasonable to achieve
that i should hopefully surpass it and
so um
i think when we go into expectations
around education and skill acquisition
and thinking about things on the the
continuum of
am i closer or further from my goal as a
result of this decision
many times we will think much more
favorably about our experience and be
significantly less frustrated
with what might be perceived as a
momentary
quote setback which isn't even a setback
it's only a setback because we think it
is
rather than i am 22 of my 38 steps along
the way
and i just need to continue to identify
which of the bricks that i am missing
to get me to my goal which is ultimately
the role um which is why so many
you know billionaires etc talk about
having good mentors because they can
look at your skill set they can look at
your bridge and say
this is what's missing this is what you
need and the thing is is that when it's
sometimes that last brick it's that one
thing that you need
that you didn't see and then all of a
sudden you attribute all your success to
that person when in reality
it was because you spent four years
building the other bricks so anyways
hope that was valuable for you hope that
made sense uh keep being awesome
and uh having a happy and productive
life alright lots love
stay real bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you